and thank you if you've been rocking
with us
since the beginning we're 200 episodes
in now yeah
and uh i mean i think that
we owe a big thank you to you yeah and
it's it really is genuinely crazy you
know when you look at the start of the
podcast matter of fact i think i think
luke and the team have prepared
a little flashback for us so why don't
we just get emotional for a second
and
take a trip through time
four years ago told you
what's up guys welcome to tmg podcast hi
reporting live from my living room this
is the tiny meat gang podcast episode
one
and your [ __ ] smells like spearmint
afterwards yeah no i'm kidding i don't
know what is that outfit definitely not
spearmint
face down there i can confirm definitely
smell the experiment yeah i'm good
kanye breast the logitech maxo creams
lodge dick yeah logitech large dick
forgot all about this
yeah
malone brown you hear this wow that was
150. in your mouth
damn
damn
sword and sweet
i was really enjoying that yeah i know i
wanted it i kind of wanted to see more
yeah
whoa bro wait wait pull up that pull up
pull up the video again and go back to
that outfit that i had on
i think we got to tear into this a
little bit oh definitely
one
one
yeah and then your [ __ ] smells like
spirit right now what am i what is this
yeah what are those boots you were
bro you were fully embracing the west
side look
you were surprised i didn't have one of
those stupid [ __ ] felt hats all right
man i'm just gonna i'm gonna leak
i feel like it's relevant but
just because the way you look but a
line in my new set that i'm doing on
wednesday is
i think me
you
it's people are gonna get some strays
here but it's fine
danny
curtis and drew
a good reason why we blew up on youtube
is because we all look like lesbians
for the beginning of our careers
i mean you guys still do i cut my hair
and i don't i don't have i just got more
yeah you got more lesbian yeah you're
butch as hell now
but right here
yeah you definitely look like a lesbian
what am i doing
dude the [ __ ] the chelsea boots man
with the forest green sweater i mean i'm
i'm not i'm not any better like what
what is going on i got the most sixth
grader outfit possible yeah those
gumshoe vans it's a little bit like
cloak gang too
yeah the distressed jeans oh it's it's
bad though it looks disconnected like
the kid like you match the shoes to the
we both did we matched the shoes and
furniture yeah
dude how ugly was this [ __ ] studio
awful what what is this because you know
what it was like why you put down the
carpet and the chairs and we're like ah
this is good no because our plan was to
do the uh the typical podcasting we were
going to cover all the walls with wood
was it yeah it was and then we looked
into the cost and we were like wait
no that's too much two hundred dollars
oh no
it was way more than that was it yeah we
didn't like we didn't know any set
builders so but you gotta remember we
still were not making money from the
podcast at this point no it started
making money around now because i
remember this is where we took the call
with the advertisers in this room yeah
but i think like this episode we still
had
zero dollars from this podcast besides
youtube ad revenue which was nothing
yeah i mean and and
i mean like the patreon was definitely
covering like the
patreon stuff yeah yeah yeah
but um
i'm stupid no but i think that you know
brings up a good point is about all of
the show which is
uh
i i feel like
you know early on not many people know
this but
you made a point like you were like all
right dude let's just figure out how we
can just take everything and put it back
into the show yeah and i think that has
definitely been what's carried us to
this point oh yeah it's made it so much
more fun yeah well just it feels good
knowing that like when obviously when
you guys like support like we just look
at the income more like what's the
weirdest craziest thing we could do yeah
um we used to have ideas all the time
with like what we just did with the
weight yeah with the weights where we
were like yeah that'd be funny but we
just like that's it resources it's like
well maybe one day we'll do it yeah and
now it feels good
you know that we can actually make that
[ __ ] come to life mm-hmm also because
all thanks to the wonderful ship and the
wonderful team here yeah you know it
helps to have a state-of-the-art system
that can literally work you
literally warp in anything at any time
so
but yeah
the
[ __ ]
the original ddp now i'm just getting
all nostalgic
this is nuts though yeah
yeah i would have liked to see a few
uh tour episodes in there yeah
[Laughter]
what a nightmare that year was yeah we
really have to thank you all for
sticking through us or sticking with us
through that period oh yeah oh you're
talking about the episodes that we did
on tour yeah those were complete ass
when i would you know cody would go eat
a beignet and i would text and be like
all right man we have to do two episodes
in a broom closet we're like it's our
day off why or it's right before the
show yeah and my ass was like nah man
let's just do it man let's get it done
now
people need the podcast they need it we
have to provide
what are people gonna do
we're going to ruin their saturdays so
we have to ruin people's saturdays
their weekend is going to be too
relaxing
no all you have to chew into a mic for
these people
dude i'm just thinking about the episode
in australia when we're in that
conference room yeah
this lady just opened the door and
you're like hey hey what's up
just walk down you're like
what the [ __ ] was that
you know didn't they say some [ __ ] to us
yeah they said something they were kind
of rude yeah and we were like
you cannot see what's happening here
we're in the middle of a [ __ ]
recording is that not completely obvious
right here
bye
bye
like we had reserved the conference
center yeah so it was uh like we had did
nothing wrong and she was like giving a
tour and she opened the door and she's
like this is the conference room i think
yeah and she was just like yeah sort of
talking through what we were doing um i
remember being really excited there too
because the internet was good yeah which
it's just not a thing at hotels still
2021
and the internet at every hotel in the
world is absolute dog [ __ ] yeah you
would you would get booked all year
every single day if you just
did a marketing campaign for your new
hotel about how good the wi-fi is yeah
right you would be like oh definitely
i'm going there i don't even i have no
plans to go to [ __ ]
albuquerque but i'll go there just to
use that wi-fi hotel yeah there need to
be
hotels it where gigabit is offered yeah
and if you just had a bulletproof
wireless network oh man yeah you'd have
you know if assuming touring comes back
you'd have every band every whoever
trying to stay there yep it would be uh
we should just build one man yeah in
albuquerque yeah
the worst town ever
you know what i realized there's there's
like no hotels in malibu
there aren't it's crazy that's got to be
a
somewhat of an opportunity i feel like
the permits are hard to get yeah that's
probably it
and i bet you all the rich people up
there don't want taurus
uh yeah man it's like entirely taurus as
it is yeah but i just mean like they
probably don't want them staying there
it's some like elitist [ __ ] you can eat
the fish you can drive through but stay
down there dukes yeah go to the pier
yeah enjoy but just get the [ __ ] out
yeah
once they close up shop close your mouth
and leave and leave
yeah that's what they want
now i'm just uh going through my head
what other
um
we had
oh it was i think it was it was at penn
state
we did it in like a dressing room yeah
it was that episode and we did several
in dressing rooms
i mean
back of the bus episodes were always
those are fun yeah turn off the ac
yep sit in the heat yep
all that yep
but now we're here and uh it's it's it's
great
um yeah it's great
it's cool it's cool i guess it's all
right it's like whatever
you